PUUUULL  -oh I got it, I got it. Okay. Okay. Hey, BUDDY.
[Poods]: NOOOO
[Brad]: OH MY GOD
*poods flies off in the distance*
BUM BUM BUM BUM BUM BUM BUM BUM BUM BUM
Aww dude iz Jackie Chance. Jackie, jackie a guy named Brad is gonna join. I want you to kill him, all right?
[Brad]: Don't kill me.
I'm a really, really big youtuber.
You don't wanna mess with me, okay?
Okay- oh my god
Oh gawd
Ahg- grab the w- sword
GRAB THE SWORD
*proceeds to grab sword inappropriately*
He's behind me, isn't he? ( ͡☉ ͜ʖ ͡☉)
[Brad]: This is terrifying.
grab the swooooord
Don't- alight
Let me get the g-  sword at least
Lemme get the sword, okay? and i'm new at this game,
be ni-
Salad@ss kill Jackie Chan. How did that happen?
[Brad]: Dude. Seriously, viking power.
*swedish viking laughs*
How did this happen?
[Brad]: Dude that was sick, bro. [Poods]: Oh, I'm gonna stab in the ass
( ͡☉ ͜ʖ ͡☉) ( ͡☉ ͜ʖ ͡☉) ( ͡☉ ͜ʖ ͡☉)
*impressed at own ass-stabbing skills*
Lokk at my KD dude! I'm killin' it- [Brad]: No.
*brad having a hard time on deciding which to grab inappropriately*
*poods commencing ass-stabbing pose*
*dear mother of god what is that*
Oookay, alright. I see- the battle begins!
[Brad]: SHIELD WAR!!!!
YEEAAAHH
The Vikiiiiing!
OOOH. OOOH.
Oh, yeah. Yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah, let me g- oh. YES.
OOHHH
Okay- kaykay
Ah dude, someone else joined.
Okay, we'll team up against him.
Hey buddy
How you doin'?
Grab it, you son of a sss-
ohh dude- Dude, he's got a spear.
*intense battle music*
What is happening? XD
Oh I got him! I got him!
Pppfffft
THAT'S RIGHT, BIIIITCH (☞⌐▀͡ ͜ʖ͡▀ )☞
Agghh? Who's dead now?
Oh okay
So it begins.
Ssso it begins
Don't come near me
DON'T COME NEAR ME
AAAAARRRGGGGHHHHH
YAAAAAHHHH YAHHH ARGHHH
Yes, the body is mine to feast upon
SALAD@SS SALAD@SS
Undefeated Gladiator (all hail to the salad@ss) undefeated.. let's start
At least this one is playable, you know, oh fuck get away from me. Oh, I got it
hehe ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Where are you come back? you'll regret that
Take it then take it then come on
Brad: I've done the thing Where your arms go inside your head
Wait put that down put that down put that down put that down no no no
(damn)
*laughing noises from poods*
Brad: UUUAAAGGGHHH
Thats creepy
OH well I know this dance swell
Brad: No, I dropped it no, no, where is it? No, no, please Poods: PUNCH
Please, no please *teleports behind you* (jacksfilms reference)
Brad: I can't reach low enough to the ground
Teleports behind you
YAS, UNDEFEATED!!!
(ZERO DEATHS EVERYONE ZERO DEATHS FOR SALAD@SS)
Brad: I Just stabbed myself. I just stabbed myself
*laughs* I heard you
Brad: Tryning to pick up a sword. Are you kidding me?
You didn't die though. Did you? Brad: no, can you look at me?
Do I look ferocious oh man, yeah, you look good
You look demonic. huh
Hey, hey, come on. I can't see anything. It's a shield is covering half my screen. Brad: Oh my god. It's so annoying
Brad: I can't even pick up a weapon anymore
Brad: Something terrible has happened at the pinnacle moment. I have lost the ability to play the game
Oh my gawd, it's so oh, oh I got dude I got the power stance (GOT 'EM) I'm sorry, but you've lost
Mm-hmm. Fight me. Brad: Oh my god. What are you doing?
What happened to the shield the plan? Brad: Nooooo, got your wheel
Brad: I guess this is it, man.
No, I get it I get over here
We need a proper duel and we need it
*laughs* What did you do with a kitchen knife thing? Yeah, we need a lot. We need a subplot. So it was you
Brad: We meet again.  Salad@ss: we meet again.
Brad: Father has died and the throne will be mine. Poods: You were supposed to bring balance to the force.
Brad: I HATE YOU
I'd loved you Braddokin
You were like a brother to me Brad: I will bring peace to my new empire
What do you got what do you got what do you got
NOOOOOOO *rip headphone user*
(SALAD@SS WINS) *EARRAPE*
That was it
I didn't even touch you and I didn't even try to touch are you kidding me
(lmao)
So useless my god
Brad: You will be a better King than , oh this is my final gift to you
Brad: *coughing while dying*
Can we do one where you win at least
I don't understand why you're so bad
I'll try the axe this time. Maybe the axe is the
It's why you've been failing because you've been grabbing the worst weapons Brad: I've killed myself
It's why you've been failing because you've been grabbing the worst weapons. Brad (again): I've killed myself
*dying poods noises* *skrattaring horse*
Brad: I'm so bad at this game
Brad: Dude, WTF-
Ooooooh oh my god, dude
Brad: Oh my god
Oh Oh we have someone Japanese
Brad: oshikuru
Konnichiwa Koushi Katyo. Brad: Konnichiwa oshikuru onjoo Poods: (best Japanese I've ever heard) Hajimemashite
Dude when he least expects it hit him with it. Oh my wah, all right.
Brad: yeah, yeah,yeah
He'll understand what that means okay i'm going I go for it he's looking I'm going for it he he he
Hey Koushi (☞⌐▀͡ ͜ʖ͡▀ )☞
Hey Koushi
KOUSHI!!
OMAE WA MOU SHEINDERU (meme reference lmao had to google it)
Brad: This is me
*earrape* *dying* *RIP* OHHH SHII-
Oh shit Ohhh (dem legs tho)
too bad
SHINDEIRU KOUSHI!!! how am I undefeated at this game? (⌐▀͡ ͜ʖ͡▀ ) I don't understand. Are you..? Brad: What the hell-
*SKRATTAR*
Hurrayyy
Nope, not today not so fast
Brad: Bitch     Salad@ss: NO
Brad: This is for all the time. Let it die on my own sword. Poods: I guess I will have to go full out
forgive me master just this once
*epic asian background fighting music*
*(KAAMEHAAAAAAME)HAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAA
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHH*
*rip headphone user*
Brad: This is the creepiest thing I've ever seen   GET AWAYYY
WHY AREN'T YOU DYING??!
BRRRRRRRRRAAHHHHHHH
*dying horse sounds*
Brad: WOAH WA-
*moaning sounds ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)*
Brad: NO NOOOOOOOOOOOOO *Brad's dying sounds*
Once again the (salad@ss) Viking wins ᕙ(▀̿̿Ĺ̯̿̿▀̿ ̿) ᕗ
(ZERO DEATHS)
I'm starting to think I'm invincible or something
all credit goes to gabe avocado and me (ragged kiddo) for these subtitles go sub us plz (first draft by kpmf_ on ig)
K then I will
thx